so this is your second rom-com together
the first one being holiday so I was
just wondering what were the advantages
of doing that second rom-com together
well I think that it was uh like an
evolution in in the work that we did on
on holiday like I really enjoyed that it
was it was different in the way of the
subject matter we were kind of tackling
and also the position that the tone and
and the position each other's character
was in in their life and it just felt
like I mean I really really wanted to
work together again after holiday we had
such a good time making it but we were
really conscious that we wanted to make
the right one next and and this was
really just perfect we just
um Emma found the script and and and
sent it through and sent me a message
saying I had to do it and yeah I um I
Julie Julie agreed and and and and uh
did as I was told and uh and I think it
worked out really really well so that
was intentional then the very because
they are very different in tone yeah we
wanted him to be we wanted yeah we
wanted the ones that we were doing the
next one to do that to not to not be the
same thing we wanted to it to be you
know
um yeah just a an evolution I think in
in what we've done before and I think um
this was certainly it so what is it
about Alan and Michelle that kind of
Drew you two to these characters into
this script I mean for me I I'm excited
for people to see this movie because I
feel like so many people I know are like
at this point in their lives I think
it's like my generation of like okay am
I moving forward with someone or am I
starting over or you know like is
marriage still relevant is like there's
just all these questions that are in The
Ether for people my age that I think
Michelle and Alan are tackling and I
think that they're look there's no right
or wrong answer it's something that you
know
um everyone needs to figure out for
themselves but you know Michelle and
Ellen are an example of how that can
kind of be unfurled and maybe I do
Michelle has this great moment where she
kind of spells out what loving each
other for the rest of your life is going
to look like and I found that
particularly resonant so I want to know
if that was something that the two of
you found important as well yeah I think
I don't know there's that I think Emma's
got a really beautiful line I think in
the bit you're talking about where she
says something along the lines of how
can you how can we guarantee we won't go
crazy when we're already crazy kind of
thing and and I kind of love that that
sentiment that
that what are you looking in the future
for if every day you've got to wake up
and and and and find a love in each day
and I thought that was a really
beautiful sentiment and and yeah I think
that was a really nice kind of lesson
that that's probably my character's
issue is that he's he's too worried
about what could go wrong rather than
what is going right at the moment and
what will continue to go right if you
keep your kind of heart and mind in in
that spot so yeah I think that's a
really beautiful sentiment that them is
character has so Emma I have to ask um
you're going to be appearing in Madame
web next year and they just want to know
what it was like getting that call from
Marvel and that was very unexpected I
was um it's just it's so funny it's like
one day you're just walking around your
house and then you get a phone call that
they won't want to meet you for a Marvel
movie and it's like so it was so weird
because I remember being like what's the
audition process like what do I have to
do
um and then I talk to the director and I
was in Boston a couple weeks later
filming and we had a lot of fun on it
it's obviously such an amazing cast and
it's such a unique take on a Marvel
movie so I'm really excited for people
to see it because I think it's not it's
going to be very unexpected how they
tell the story and Luke you were in
Elvis recently speaking of big projects
um our baslerman films really large
Larger than Life up close as they seem
yeah they probably they might even be
bigger
I mean it's pretty yeah it's it's pretty
crazy when you rock up to work and then
you just see kind of 500 people dressed
like it's
1971 walking past you into a giant Sound
Stage that's like the rebuilt
International Hotel theater and yeah
yeah it was absolutely insane and it and
it just kept going and then then there's
Tom Hanks there as well and it was just
it was pretty special every day on that
set was was so exciting and and baz is
such a genius and and and so yeah I it
was crazy it was wild it's hard to kind
I haven't really thought about it in a
while actually so without thinking about
I was like yeah that wasn't quite an
amazing experience it was it was surreal
I love that movie so much yeah thank you
so circling back to rom-coms now
um obviously the two of you like
rom-coms this is your second one that
you're doing together
um what is your go-to rom-com that isn't
one of yours I mean I Love My Best
Friend's Wedding I absolutely love and
then I love bridesmaids it always it
always makes me laugh every time
um mine's a bit more calm but it's
definitely got rum in it wedding crashes
it's definitely what like wedding
crashes I think is so awesome so um
but also I watched
um when we were filming this and Hammer
and I were talking about it I wish
um Runaway Bride and that's so good that
movie love runaway ride that movie is
amazing so yeah they're the ones that
are in my mind
okay so all of these are wedding themes
so this is great tie into my last
question which is
so Alan and Michelle's story kind of
kicks off with what is quite possibly an
extremely embarrassing event one of the
most embarrassing events you could have
at a wedding so what is like the most
embarrassing thing you've seen at a
wedding
like mine as I fell down the stairs at
my cousin's wedding in my bridesmaids
dress so
that's good I I was um I was a
bridesmaid and my girlfriend had us all
wearing white even though she was
wearing white and somebody knocked over
a bottle of red wine that went like all
down my dress before I had to give the
speech and it looked so bad that I had
to wear like someone's suit jacket over
it but then I I actually hung it up
later and it looked almost like art like
it was so bad that it was good it just
looked like this is gothic like romance
horror bridesmaid dress I still have it
hanging in the closet with the wine
stains oh that's great
um I went I won't name names because I
would never do that but I certainly know
of this moment when I guest at a wedding
was just tearing the Dance Floor up and
then accidentally tore the tuxedo pants
from after front and spent the whole
night with their underpants hanging out
of their tuxedo pants and it was really
funny and and it was wasn't me it wasn't
me
but it was really really funny and I
think everyone and this person took it
in a great great humor and it was yeah
very very funny so it didn't stop them
from cutting up the Dance Floor the rest
of the night I don't know I think I
think they were like they're in for a
penny in for a pound now all right well
thank you both so much congratulations
again on the movie thank you thank you
thank you so much have a great day